have you ever looked at a game like
ghost of sushima and wondered wow how
did they do this luckily they were
pretty open about talking about how they
did it let's go through their GDC talk
and we'll Implement something similar
based on their ideas so to get started
they begin by chopping up the world into
tiles tiles are used to drive various
parameters of the world from artists and
whoever else then they move on to
describe their compute Shader setup from
the sounds of it this is used to
generate the per instance grass blade
dat
so where they are how they Bend
basically everything about each blade of
grass that'll be consumed by the vertex
Shader so I mean the gist of it is they
generate a bunch of data per grass plate
so the first order of business is of
course making that tile of grass we'll
build an individual blade of grass using
these vertex IDs or vert IDs and I'll
just use the vertex Shader to create
positions from that then we'll instance
this a number of times generating a
unique position for each blade of grass
this gets us our very first completely
uniform set of grass in the talk they
place the individual Blades of grass
using a jittered grid of points so you
start with evenly spaced points and then
just apply a small random offset to each
one this ensures reasonably uniform
coverage they also talk about using
voronoi noise to give them some ways of
clumping the grass for artistic purposes
giving them controls for clumping and
clustering we can pretty much just copy
this Jitter approach verbatim so what I
do here is just apply a small random
offset to each blade of grass as they
mentioned in the talk I'm going to skip
out on the voronoi for the time being I
get the feeling that it's not absolutely
necessary and we can just start simple
we can also add some angle variation by
rotating each blade I'm just doing that
in the Shader via per blade hash value
that I generate why am I not using web
GPU good question I probably should but
I'm doing this in JavaScript and doing
it this way will probably make it more
broadly compatible with anybody who
wants to try the code out later let's
move on to some details of the grass
itself in their talk Sucker Punch
mentions they use a cubic bezi a curve
to model the shape of the grass they
have a few parameters including a tilt
and bend which is used to curve the
grass blade so the basic idea at least
what I'm getting out of it is that you
need a mechanism to shape the grass
blade so that it curves they use a
bezier as pictured here since you can
manipulate the control points to give
you a lot of control over the shape of
the curve and
animation I mean we could just go with
that the code is right here since I had
to make the animation but I fiddled
around a bit and ended up just using a
simple rotation of the vertex on the x-
axis based on the height and a random
per blade curve value gives me a really
similar effect so I'm content and it
show shows that there are multiple paths
to achieve the effect although who knows
this may come back to bite me later but
let's not dwell on what ifs the next
additions they make are by using a
slightly rounded normal in place of the
flat grass normal so you can see here
that they've got an artist Supply normal
map for the blade of grass I don't have
an artist handy so I chose to hack this
into the Shader with two rotated normals
and I blend between them if I'm not
supervised I will will just hack at
things the effect seems to be pretty
similar I get a rounding of each blade
in my lighting test bed everything seems
good the lighting seems to work just
fine I guess I could have just taken
their texture by screencapping the video
but oh well and then they apply a subtle
view space adjustment based on your
viewing angle and the direction the
blade is facing they say that they
slightly shift the verts and view space
there's no real details here but I kind
of screwed around with with it I kind of
just shift the verts in view space
before the final transform is written
out based on this kind of view space
thickening factor which is based on the
dot product of the view Direction and
the grass normal I just fed that through
this easing function and then ramp it
down as we go completely orthogonal
otherwise you get this weird crisscross
with the other side I didn't spend a lot
of time experimenting here you can
definitely see that the grass is Lusher
and Fuller like this we can zoom in and
see this individual blade as I Pan the
camera around kind of trying its best to
stay on screen and then it gives up at
some point it's an awesome trick it
works great even with my incredibly lame
phoned inversion let's move on to
lighting and colors so they have some
artists authored textures for their
grass which controls gloss and color
they enable specular but blend it with
the terrain normal to avoid aliasing and
probably the biggest thing is that they
generate their own simple ambient
occlusion
now we've cranked up the amount of grass
a bit and I'll do the exact same thing
I'll have a simple gradient going from
base to tip and I'm going to pick my own
colors here so we'll go with a darkish
green at the base and a sort of
yellowish at the tip I can control this
with a simple shaping function with the
specular I'm just blending the normal
with the up Vector based on distance
I'll fiddle more with the parameters
later but we've got the code in place
now and finally the ambient occlusion
term so this value is being generated in
a really basic way starting with some
overall density we'll assume that we
fill that in later and we'll remap that
into a shading range fully dense areas
will get a lot more shading than sparer
ones and then we adjust based on the
height so this is kind of starting to
resemble grass so they mentioned that
they have some sort of global wind
system driven by pein noise and that can
be sampled on both the CPU in the GPU
there's apparently a second talk that
goes into more details but I don't feel
like watching that I'm going to run with
the pearlin noise keyword so first I
want to get some basic movement going so
I take a sample of the noise based on
the grass position and I scroll that
with time and I just add that on top of
the curve of the grass blade this kind
of adds some subtle
movement then I take another couple
samples of noise one is interpreted as
the direction of the wind and get get
remapped into the range 0 to
360° the second sample is the strength
of the wind and then we just scroll both
of those with time then I apply that as
a rotation on the vertices in the same
way we do the curve but based on the
wind direction the end result is a lot
stiffer instead of that Flappy effect
they showed which looks awesome their
whole game looks awesome but similarly
I'm seeing what other ways we can do
this and how those turn out I based this
on some footage of plants in the wind I
I captured a few weeks ago on my way to
Toronto in reality you just do whatever
looks good to you I feel like this looks
pretty nice but keep in mind I don't
have an artistic Vision here if a lot of
this has looked interesting to you and
you want to be able to do similar work I
happen to have a Shader and math course
that teaches you from the ground up we
work from Total beginner to some pretty
Advanced topics like we're doing right
now there links in the description now
the final piece of the puzzle is the L
of detail system they have two levels
High which has 15 vertices and low which
has seven then they blend from high to
low I'm going to do something hand wavy
similar I'll Define high and low and
that'll determine how many vertices are
in each blade of grass I'm going to be
super cheap and make the far away grass
just a single quad so the high detail
will lose its curvature as it
transitions from high to low and I'll
just hot swap them for each other
once that's in you can see that I've
placed like at least a jillion more
Blades of grass into the scene where
somewhere in the millions at this point
but this is taking something like 1.5
milliseconds on the GPU we could
definitely ring out more performance
they're way more aggressive and swap out
four high level of detail tiles for one
low it may be worth checking that out
but they were productionizing the system
and I'm just screwing around here at
this point it's probably up to you to
hone in on some settings that work
pretty well for you ghost of sushima
uses thinner Blades of grass and bends
them a lot so they get that nice
specular reflection going which I sort
of have a similar setting here after
fiddling around with the
parameters tweaking the lighting and
colors a bit more and I added a layer of
basically crap on top the little
butterflies and puffs are just Shader
driven nonsense but I really like the
wind swep planes look that we have going
so what we have looks pretty decent as
is I've gone ahead and added some other
stuff into the scene some terrain some
different sky and fog settings tweak the
lighting water with a screen space
reflection and tens of thousands of
trees I know we didn't follow the talk
100% but at the same time I always view
these as more inspiration and a Rough
Guide rather than a rigid set of steps
to follow the end result looks pretty
nice so I'm content and as always this
is running in the browser which is
really neat cheers